he's going to present how to map or
thinner structure internetwork graphs to
understand protein folding so please
give him a welcome applause okay okay
guys and girls thanks very much for have
coming here you are very brave to hit
200 be here I am very happy and I would
like to also thank the organizer to I
select my obstructed so I have the
opportunity to present my work so we
start with answering this question Who
am I well I am a Twitter no I am Maximo
and this is my Twitter okay
I even if I am from very long time ago I
just start to use two weeks ago
and I found it very nice especially very
recently in during this talk I also like
to tweet and I think it's very nice
because it's a way of exchanging
information so I love it and I was born
in Sicily 31 years ago and and I studied
in Catania computer science and then I
went in the north of Italy to study in
Vilonia to study an international master
in CS eating goes over Sciuto
studying the bioinformatics and thanks
to this master I moved to Spain in
Barcelona where pan couldn't come to
Makkah was very where is very nice and I
studied biotechnology and actually I did
my PhD I got my PhD two years ago and
then from from Barcelona I went to to
Cambridge in UK and then in Germany in
English again so always working in
computational crystallography and
protein structure folding okay but why
am i year well the reason is basically
free I will add one one more the first
one actually is because I love Python as
all of you the second one is because I
love
for Mattox maybe not everybody knows it
but actually exists it field and it's
very nice because it's an intermediate
step between computer science and life
sciences
so my informatician are very cool and
then science I love science as probably
most of you that you are in this room
and also research and I know it's very
difficult to stay in academia and say
that I and I know personally but I think
that if you really love you should do it
then what is a protein ok we start with
that and the answer actually Asha shanks
Oscar to give a very nice introduction
so mine will be fast and I we can define
the protein in four different levels
okay and the first level is just a
sequence of the amino acids these 21
building blocks that that shape all the
star all the proteins okay but the
proteins
it's themselves are never packed in a
linear sequence in the Indus cells they
work as a structure so they they fold
themselves in a three-dimensional shape
which we are interested on study and
these tertiary structures of the shape
that the protein apply actually have
some regular folds that are called
secondary structures so we all have
facilities and beta strands that are
that are present in all the proteins in
all the structure and we can take care
of that because it's important for my
work so now I would like to just give
you this brief introduction on what is a
protein again so all the human living
with all the living beings they
ourselves as you might know probably
otherwise you should go to take some
class in biology and then because we are
air carriers so we have nucleus and in
peace nuclear there is a very important
thing that is our DNA that contains all
the genetic information from which is
possible to generate to create the
proteins so in the chromosome the DNA is
is parked in in a specific
and then we have Jean with a portion of
his DNA that actually contained
information for producing protein so
there are special enzymes so complex of
proteins that recognize the genes and
starts to translate a transcript the
correct term to the the meaning on the
DNA creating these RNA messenger that us
Oscar was speaking about that is impel
important because it's actually what
carry the information the all the
necessary information to create proteins
so the RNA we will not enter into the
days but will mature with some
modifications so alternative splicing
etc we give Aaron a is modified and when
it's ready it will move out from the
nucleus and it's we go out out of the
nucleus where it will encounter other
other enzymes that the ribosome so
ribosome is a special enzyme that that
is able to recognize the teaser renamed
messenger and thanks with a coordinated
with the help of tRNA
it in translate the code on mRNA to
produce protein so each tRNA are bring
us one specific amino acid and the list
is amazing mechanism in nature that
there is a correspondence between them
three letters in their na with one amino
acid in for the protein and so you see
it looks like you know going in and in
an industry and see all that we are
building something but actually he's
happens constantly in ourselves is
amazing and then when the protein is
ready when the all the sequence is
created then the it falls automatically
instantaneously in a 3d shape we are
interested in this free t-shirt the
reason why we are interesting the pretty
shape is because the shape the structure
of the protein is what is drive the see
the function of the of the protein
everything all the things that happens
in our in our cells
happens because there are products that
they do these these things so we need to
know what they do as for knowing for new
for new what what they do we need to
understand the structure so what I mean
for a structure and so I mean this so
this is our disease our human blood
cells and and a decision among Levine
I'm ugly we these are very important
protein because it's doing something for
important is is carrying the oxygen in
our blood so it's maintaining oxygenated
the cells and the way how is doing that
is because of the structure so the
structure of this protein is is is in
such a way that it's possible to have
these movements and you can see here our
in this Hemi group we can find an ion
hot on that attract this oxygen and can
free this option this oxygen in a
specific moment and this will actually
perform the function of this structure
so what I mean is structure is
everything because structure is what
drives the function so now that we
understand ER stood why we need to
understand the function and the
structure we just I will just summarize
that again that we all the proteins of
two particular fold that are always
present in you know the in other
structures like - like beta sheets that
we can in the cartoon representation we
can just summarize up to arrows and
helices that are also very common okay
so this is the mo glavine that i show
you before any and max Perutz
in 1962 won the Nobel Prize to up
discover this protein disease that such
kind of importance that that that is
structural so oh you can describe a
protein structure in something that is
computational affordable so you can you
can simply the so each is so the
structure is made by amino
seed amino acids are made by atoms so we
can list all the atoms in a PDB in a
file effects file for example this is
what we call PDB file so what kind of
information we found we have information
about the atoms we have information
about the amino acids so the type of the
amino acids the chain we have the number
in the sequence where this amino acid is
found and then most important for me at
least we have the coordinates so we have
the X Y Z and Z record received
coordinates in the space of each atom
okay
this is very nice for visualization and
these allow us to draw this kind of
representation for proteins but if we
need to interpret the structure we need
to do some some generalization so what
we have done in our group is create a
method that transform this coordinates
in something that is more mathematical
interpretable
vectors so without entering the details
how is best westeros trail where created
we actually generate a series of vectors
that represent both the beta strands and
the acai Ellis's and we can really
recognize them by the property of the
vectors for example the magnitude of
these vectors will tell us directly if
if this vector belongs to us enough a
little fracture order or to a beta one
so if you look here this is a car tool
it's yes it's a fixed representation of
free anti-parallel bit of strength so
what I do is generate a series of vector
representing these these t structure and
then I create a graph in which each node
corresponds to a characteristic a vector
and an edge connecting to two nodes is
actually the three-dimensional
relationship between ventis vectors so
if you are two vectors in the space you
can compute distances you can compute
angles and many other things
so all these it becomes a metric in my
in my edge okay so if we move you
the notes corresponds it corresponds to
directors so okay so there are different
way of of using working with with with
graph and in Python actually what you
really need is just have a matrix for
represent our graph but there are very
good some good packages like for a use
Python I graph there are also others
like network is that
Geordie represented yes yesterday for
the first day and the differences is
basically that network is if I am NOT
wrong should be all in Python right
while while apart on a graph of the
currency so for some kind of algorithms
can be faster than then your so you
depends but I will tell you Python a
graph is or a buffer for visualization
so if you want to generate graphs you
should do something different but I'm
interesting on the calculus on the
computing and so if you scan these you
will get the page where download Python
is okay so go to we have a fracture okay
Tufte structures one in fifty nine
doesn't matter what is it for for us
it's it's a free layer sandwich so it
means that we have alpha realities we
have bit of friends here in the middle
and other our sinuses so again we can
compute all the vectors and for each
vector we have a node and then we have
all the edges connecting to the all the
nodes so representing the
three-dimensional relationship our kind
of graph are full it means that for each
two node it exists always our connection
our undirected because the angle between
two vectors or the distance between the
vectors doesn't matter the order in
which you look at it and awaited so it
means we wait using a metric we wait the
distances of these vectors in the space
not just using the distance but also
considering on the angle and setter
okay so now this is not really clear
because I did is like 469 and it is a
different resolution value so it's okay
so what I want to show here actually is
how to create a graph so a part of
importing my own libraries which is
normal
when you are working what I'm doing is
reading a PDB structure and this you can
done it with some libraries like value
Python and Klaudia will show you how to
do that and then you I create all these
series of vectors we discuss with
function so all these vectors that I
showed you before and then if I want to
create a graph in with algebra what they
do is calling G's equal Heydrich dot
plus so I create this graph then you can
add vertices with just a simple called
hard vertices and the number of vertices
but in my case because it's a fool it's
a complete graph I can directly use this
constructor full
let's give me also not only the vertices
but also all all the edges good then you
can in graph your graph as two objects
that grasp assets there's a sequence the
basic sequence and the hatch sequence
that actually are two iterators for
iterate over the the edges and over
there the vertices and each node the
each node each vertex is you can treat
it as a dictionary so you can put
keywords properties on on these on this
node for example the secondary structure
type is this not belonging to us many
species goal node belonging to our
business trends and then you can also
assign properties to the edges for
example the most important property for
an edge is the weight as I told you
before okay so what you can do with the
graph where the first thing you can do
is for example we can filter the graph
and that you can you can do in in in I
guess you can do with select so you can
use this funky function select both for
the against the vertices or against the
edges and automatically automatically
fight on a graph create special keywords
for each one of the keywords that you
have configured for your your own node
so before we have created for for all
the nodes are keywords at what cost SSA
type so now automatically I can select I
can reduce my
my graph by using the keyword that I
have for the nonce exercise and then I
have underscore in to tell that I want
to extract all the all the notes in
which the property assess a tile is is
inside this business with this case you
have just one element you could shoot
for use for example equal that means
equal but it's just to show you the
opportunity of doing that another way
for example for selecting is against the
edges so we can select by reducing the
number of edges and for example I want
to have only be hedges in which the
distance properties is greater than four
feet but less sorry or less or equal
than fortified so very easily you can
create this the filters and then you can
call sub graphs here to get the new
graph with only the edges of the
vertices that you have selected
and then after that you can write this
standard format in XML graph ml and I do
that because I told you
Python a graph is very enjoyable for for
creating the the visualization so I use
these rough ml to represent it then with
another program and I'll show you
but so the first the first the first
filtering just for the biggest friend I
got this for example I won't just a bit
of strength so this is the filtering
what happens to my structure when I
filter the graph with his weight is only
the bit of strength and this is what
happened to my structure if I eliminate
all the distances that are greater than
40 Armstrong and less or equal than 45
amps so you see you can do these things
okay if graph a smelly format it's I
don't like XML I prefer JSON in general
but this is what they they gave to me
and this is so you can you can create
from the scratch your own graph and then
you can use for example G Jessie that is
a visual is a visually setter for graphs
and you can and you can do this but you
can do the same in Valka or in other as
you prefer so the visualization is
really as you prefer to do it okay so
what the first application want to talk
about with the structure and graph is
comparing two structures so now we are
using a toy gate very easy okay because
for the for this so we have to be last
this is the mathematical way of
representing a graph so graph one is the
set is the combination of the set of the
vertices and the edges well okay so we
have these these graphs here free
antiparallel strands then we have
another graph free antiparallel strands
they looks very similar but when you go
into the details actually they are not
they are not equivalent okay in this
tool if you look to the graph
corresponding you easily see that for
example in this strand here we have a
character e vector less we lack of
vectors it means that this this trend
here is longer than the others so what
we want to find what is the maximum
common superclass
that is the core the core of the of the
diffic wallet in the two graphs we want
to find that because if we if we can
compare to structure as both are but I
told you before structure is what dry
the function define and if I know this
if I know that structure of one protein
and that can compare to another
structure then I can infer the function
of the second protein because of a
similar structure so it's important to
know comparing structures okay so we are
these two graphs what can we do is
compute an edge product graph that is a
new graph is a new graph in which and
follow women with that so in this new
graph we take all the edges of the first
graph and all the edges of the second
graph and we make it in they became our
new nodes in this graph so the nodes on
this graph they are actually the edges
in in in that graph and then the edge is
connecting two nodes in this new product
graph is actually the correlation is the
correlation between them the edges of
the of these two graphs this new graph
is telling us how each edge of the first
class correlate to each edge to the
second graph so it's a way of
automatically comparing them
automatically known if they are similar
or not this correlation is como is
computed like this with this formula and
we
but so when you see a strong hedge here
it means that these ads on the first
graph and these ads on the second graph
we are very correlated they are very
similar so they are we say super
portable yes it is just there the
general formula so if you are a vector
so you can represent the edge with a
vector and a range of properties I'm not
going into the face
but there are distances angles and etc
so these vectors of products of
properties here you can multiply you can
you can compute the scalar product with
another vector so that the first you
will be the first vector we will be the
second pair vector and it is the norm
if the knob of the of the visitor of it
works it's for normalization okay but in
any case you get these and you say okay
I have a strong correlation on these two
heads a strong correlation here and when
you don't almost see nothing is because
you don't think those have correlation
okay good so how do you do that okay
without going so much in the face but I
also like to name things that's
important actually because invite on a
graph when you when you start to select
fifth and cetera you cannot rely on the
index that automatically fights on a
graph is given to you because they it
will always change in it so what you
have to do is name it in the way that
you want so you can always recognize
what you are working with okay when you
have I create a new graph in which there
the number of nodes that is is the sum
of the number of edges of the first
graph plus the second one and then with
this is a suit product here you can
co-create you can do actually the
Sicilian product of all the of the of
all defect times or the second set okay
and you do that then which ship I ship
as partial distance correlation I
compute that formula to show you report
to compute the disease the correlation
between the metric that I have for the
first edge against the matrix of the
second - if this correlation is high it
means that they are very similar
he is log
means they are very very not similar if
they are similar what they mean it means
that the distance they aren't all all
the three-dimensional relationship that
they are telling us are similar it means
that they are super possible they are
comparable okay so um these graphs can
be very big and complicated so I need to
do lots of things to reduce the
complexity of these graphs and announce
the properties of of the graph so I'll
do some filtering removing edges degree
letters here at R equal to 0 find the
max the max the maximal component the
connected component etc but what is
really important here is that you are
reducing your graph and you are getting
only the most important information only
the most high correlation okay the last
step actually is creating a spawn tree
so as country what if it is a graph in
which you use all the nodes but you you
you are using the minimal number of
edges so it's sort of a way a tree if
it's a fact for for working on all the
possible correlations that I have found
and just selecting the best ones the
highest one then with the with the use
of teeth until you see the spanning tree
you can get it in demeanor bite on
either just with this comment I don't
send spanning tree and of course we
might get because it's a full graph I
need to give need to give the way
otherwise I will not get angry okay
then I extract I extract then two
possible graphs that are that are
compatible with the spanning tree here
remember again the ditch node here is an
edge
it's an edge on one of the two graphs so
it means that actually contains two
vertices so what I am doing is that in a
certain distance is not here and
splitting in the original diversity of
vertices and I create what is comparable
if is a morphic is the more singing
graph it means that actually you can
superpose
so then the edges and the vertices are
completely equivalent in the two graphs
and you can just check is too
PR is overseen by calling this function
if I don't address are very easy so as
you can see if you are the are even more
speed and what happens to my structure
look we are now to is a morphing drug we
have found the core so now we have a
direct correspondence between each node
and each edge and so what we can do is
selecting that color the maximum common
core and use that coordinates for
superposing for aligning in 3d the to
structure and we are moving from a from
a structure that is not aligned to one
that means maximize an align okay that's
just one toy case simple application the
last thing that I want to talk is about
another possibility identity that's just
for understand how easy you can do how
much things easier things you can do
with graphs for structure for example
proteins they are not working alone we
have also seen the video in which we
have these ribosomes ribose a ribosome
are not just one protein and made of
complex of Roger so this protein they
must interact each other but they cannot
interact in whatsoever because I've made
by atoms and if you know a little bit
about chemistry you know that three
atoms they do not interact randomly so
an atom can interact can form some bones
if actually is if has some available
space to form this kind of bond so in
proteins of interfaces it means the
direct there are region of the project
that are most accessible to interact
with other proteins imprint a region of
the product that are not accessible to
interact for example is easy to see here
that the core of this protein is well it
is buried inside so it's difficult for
another project to interact or enter
interact with is why for example this
region here if it's really open and it
can be easily in more access accessible
to the for further project so what you
can do is building up again a full graph
as before and then for example you can
compute a centrality x' with
eigenvectors so again in photography
just calling a function G as
you call the function is important to
scale your value can you scale your
values and then in my case is an
undirected graph
I want that pata Negra also written the
agent values for each one of the nodes
then I usually assigned all these eigen
values to my to a property of my vector
of my nodes and then here what I'm doing
is just iterating over different values
of these are different windows of these
agent agent values and what I see here
is it's that for no no agent values solo
centrality of the nodes it means that we
are in the outer region of our structure
higher centrality of the node of these
nodes they map the inner core of my
brother so if we just freeze a line of
code in Python I can map a very
important and very important protein
properties okay so of course this is our
story case because the reality is much
more complex it's not that easy like
that but to show that really that's
really with some code you can really
extract feature from from the proteins
and you can map them automatically parse
the whole PDB structure that we have
more than 800,000 and and take all this
information at once and this end knows
about protein folding okay so the next
result will be from the - Claudia minion
and Claudia is my colleague she is
working with me and she's amazing and we
give a talk on community class saying
how to use community clustering for
projects so that I think you should not
miss it ok conclusion
phyto Naga is fast rough a Python
interface library for for networks and
graphs it allows to generate and control
graphs or small and medium-sized so if
you have very large networks you should
use your data most efficiently with some
techniques for for example streaming or
using pandas and then proteins can be
mapped into graphs by the use of
characteristic vectors that as I show
you before if you want to know more that
is multiplication
you can read it or you can ask me and
then the drug theory and there are far
greens they can be used for for solving
problem to know more about problems ok
Maya knowledge meant he/she is the best
boss in the day ever
one up so she's professor Isabel John
she's working here in Barcelona and a
pseudo BAC el Milagro de Barcelona she's
amazing and then I am young probably
will not see also my colleague and
Nicholas Pileggi also he is an amazing
boss doc he actually knows everything
about biology and chemistry I don't know
anything so the only things I know if
the things that I show you in the video
so if you want to know more about that
issue that we deem that we make up we
are a group and we are sort of a family
so I am very happy to be part of this
family act involved or team as we call
us okay thanks for your question thank
you
I think nice to see then we protein
scientists are getting to a passion
world also I work with protein structure
but with prediction purposes in my lab
and I was wondering if this could be
applied to some kind of homology
modeling for instance and if it's a very
process of assessing similarity when
they are some kind of diversity they're
not very similar bad how much of a
resolution can we ask treatment so of
course it's a very nice technical
question and now it's really nice and
actually we are collaboration with
people that are doing modeling and they
are doing actually also protein
structure prediction from the novel and
it is very nice and our methods is a
generalization right now it's very
generalization to extract extract very
fast some properties of structure for
modeling I suppose
you should go more in the base than that
but actually we artists collaboration we
want to use more than for prediction
that we want to use for validation
validation is I don't know what you know
but validation is once you have found
you have found what is the structure of
your protein you have to be sure that it
sucks exactly residue by residue
everything is correct and these can be
done this can be done with this
Kennedy's this technique can help
because can can easily map some big
errors that are happening in your main
chain so this is something that we are
doing but it's not already there but we
is something that we want to do for sure
my questions thank you for the talk very
interesting and my question is which is
the typical site the typical size in
terms of number of nodes and number of
edges that you need to represent these
kind of proteins this is very variable
because it depends on the structure so
you have to imagine that just imagine
for example if you're working you can
work with structure of 300 residues for
example and for each residue you have
five six atoms so makes the
multiplication and that's for will be
for free for free hundreds but if you
move to something big like ribosomes
then it becames and almost so the kind
of networks in which you are working are
completely different and actually
different it is a very good question
because it's different the algorithms
that you are using according the size of
your of your network so what I show here
it's a very tiny case in which you have
very small number of so for
visualization it was easier to to look
the things but when you go to very big
things then you have to sampling than
your network you have to sample your
network you have to make some assumption
and then once like a short week we can
say that like you are bigger know you
have noticed that instead of mapping one
residue
with them up a bigger portion of your
structure and once you are more or less
sure about that soup Network then you
can refine your soup Network in with
more precise algorithms so for sure this
is something that we have to do for
decades otherwise that will not fit I
will not say we will not see fit the
memory but the problem will be that the
algorithms will be never handling Emily
thank you for this very nice talk I'm
not a biologist but I enjoy grated I had
a knowledge
I had a question about something I read
about unstructured proteins they might
be much larger than what you as you just
said but these are tennis is not that a
project you mean yes you're certain
these are the naturally disordered
proteins can you see some metric with
your impressions that can distinguish
them from the structured one it's an
amazing question because actually it's
what is structural biology it's what we
cannot understand very well because
whatever it's a structure as a structure
is something that we can interpret
well once we the structure is not there
you don't know how it works and you're
under not understand why it's there but
actually there are many projects that
are structured and they are produce and
so we don't know why but it's very
interesting in any case for my of course
for my application is for structured
project so you have to have a structure
to interpret the structure and that
thing is very interesting but I think
right now the direction is more on the
possible in the energetic field that you
can have forty some structure proteins
and like creating the older folding
funnel so all the possible conformation
according to energy energetical
probabilities to fold in a specific
conformational to have at least a
general some chemical bonding the dead
month they should be maintained my
method will not work at all with this
kind of structure because you cannot
estimate the energetic environment I
don't know your configuration I do not
have any statistics for that kind of
protein so will not work F anything for
for the kind of protein but I see it's
very interesting and it's something that
will be very interesting to look but you
need to need to know more from the
biology's before what they mean well
have they work and so maybe we can
expect features so when we the by
informatician we just extract analyze
features but the features they are must
be done must be given by biology
first and that's a good point
but the prediction requires that in a
sort of term you have to so you know
when you have lots of features this is a
general things machine learning I think
if you have lots of feature and you want
to predict something from that there if
your features are correlated for example
you can misleading and you don't know
because you don't know anything about
structure so you should the first thing
that you do when you do machine learning
is understand the data that's the first
thing and you are to understand what you
are but whatever the data what they are
telling you before doing whatever
because at the at the end of the day
machine learning is statistics no matter
what what computer science is call it
and I am a computer scientist and
statistics is made of numbers and
numbers
you always get numbers but if they can
also mean anything if you are if your
data from what would your starting you
are completely useless so right now I
think we are not at the point but it
will be very nice for to be at that
point yes I think you should answer yeah
no I can add something cuz I'm supposed
to know everything about yeah of course
yeah
that could be a way of comparing
different conformation of the same
protein and and see which are the parts
which are more Labine more prone to move
I think more disordered
that could be an application as you saw
say if we can if we maybe not all the
part of the structure it's really
completely and disorder but just a part
of that yeah other questions
okay thank that is a the last one yes
and then we with ammonia and well first
of all thanks that was a great talk
thank you and you managed to pack a lot
of biology in in a very short time and I
think that's something that's remarkable
and so you've showed how this approach
can be used to align protein structures
to find this minimal core component in
tone and but you're still treating the
rest of the protein as a rigid body
right if I'm correct yes once you have
found the core then you can read your
body and find the optimal rotation
translation to superpose them and that's
one of the bucket is one of the
application which you can use it then
you can you can for example the other
application which you can use it in in
which you are splitting in pieces and
refine independently is presented by
Claudia so you have to see the next stop
if you see the next stop you will see
how so I did it as a rigid body but
Claudia don't Claudia the things that is
the question was how does this compare
to other methods for selector alignment
yeah that kind of the flexibility of the
rules so that's very also very good
question and of course this is not the
only method to propose things and
proteins but the thing is that are
usually that the methods for proposing
are based on aligning sequence before
aligning substructure and that sometimes
can have a problem if you are going to
very small fold like I show you here
free strength in which the sequence
alignment is zero so in that case you
cannot using SSM superpose secondary
structure magic superpose you cannot use
that and it doesn't just as work doesn't
work so my method is just based on
coordinates so that's their the
advantage the advantage is if you don't
if you are for example what they is
called lower molar G model it means very
two structures that are similar are
similar in 3d but are very different in
the sequence
sometimes the superposition can fail but
with this method
it doesn't fail because you use the
coordinates you don't use the sequence
at all at any time okay
depends on the structure depends on the
structure because in some structure you
can you can make more approximations
because some regularities for example
alpha Alice's have as you Europe might
have seen they have these regularities
here these modularity and you can make
use of that other structure they are
more complex and they can they can lock
this modularity so you have to really
look all that kind of all the all the
vectors and this can take more time so
as always you have to use the method
that they defeat for you if you have a
very good two sequences if you also
structure that up very good sequences
and they are 50% sequence identity what
you want to use that method you don't
doesn't want you want to use the normal
alignment but sometimes and that's for
application for example but I don't want
to go in these because of the otherwise
but there are application like phasing
methods crystallography that click
Claudia will tell you in which you can
use lower malla G models and then you
have to scribble them okay so I think
you rather don't want to steal more time
to Claudia
otherwise she kill me and so thank you
everybody
[Applause]